[Musique]
cet hiver en voyage à québec j'ai fait
la rencontre d'une femme hors du commun
bonjour madame elle s'appelle pierrette
morissette
elle conduit un taxi et être là d'orsan
les jets sont tout aussi intéressants
les uns que les autres s est déjà allé
au culot pillés
[Musique]
après avoir travaillé de nuit pendant
plus de dix ans elle a réduit ses heures
au volant à deux fois par semaine
pierre est à 72 je vois des gens dans la
quarantaine
ils font très vieux trop vieille pour
retomber en amour comme beaucoup de
femmes elle le pensait divorcé depuis 30
ans pierrette vivait seul zerg
quand je me suis marié j'étais
maintenant dans la vingtaine est ce
qu'on veut c'est avoir une famille une
maison est bon une vie de famille c'est
un but lost arrive et ça ça a été
réalisé à ottawa le phénomène de
l'âgisme fait l'objet d'études
universitaires à force de me faire dire
que l'amour et la sphère des jeunes
l'amour et la faire d'eux des jeunes
beaux et des jeunes belle ben je finis
par intérioriser cette idée là et je
finis par moi même me me mettre un
obstacle par rapport à la possibilité
comme personne âgée de retomber en amour
la docteur martin lagacé est l'une des
rares spécialistes au pays on le vus
dans toutes les études c'est le
stéréotype ont fini par l'intérieur les
époux orages et à la célibataire endurci
lé je vais vous dire depuis plusieurs
années
vous savez un monopole c'est guèye
abadan et laitiers vous savez à mon âge
je peux pas faire certaines choses roger
ferland est un ingénieur à la retraite
divorcée lui aussi livré seul en fait
les statistiques révèlent que chez les
personnes âgées de 75 ans et plus deux
hommes sur dix vivent seules chez les
femmes c'est près de quatre sur dix je
cherche à padum mais j'ai rencontré
l'homme de même il ya trois ans ils se
sont rencontrés lors de dîners sur la
rive sud de québec
piette sacha été facile au départ de
tomber en amour avec elle aussi tout que
45 50 ans on commence à être perçue
comme encore une fois moins compétents -
debout aussi c'est la course à la beauté
c'est encore plus vrai pour les femmes
parce qu'effectivement il se cumulent de
sexisme et d'agissements qui joue dans
déjà me demandait il ya quelques temps
j'hésite à rencontrer jeudi à peu près
le même âge que moi parce que je savais
que si je disais qu être avant tout le
monde va mais m'en ont dit si vieux
même à 80 3 est ce que tu peux faire le
couple vit aujourd'hui dans une maison
que roger a acheté et qu'ils ont rêvé
ensemble à saint romuald sur la rive sud
de québec la ville ou pierrette a été
conseillère municipale pendant plusieurs
années
ça c'est une de mes toiles une toile que
j'aime beaucoup elle est plus petite
mais vraiment intéressante ce sont les
amoureux ce problème sur le trottoir je
me voyais avec roger moi quand j'étais
jeune je voulais aller aux beaux-arts
mais là je réalise mon rêve depuis
disait je m'amuse dans la peine
pierrette et roger ont la chance de
vivre chez eux c'est que dans certaines
maisons de retraite retomber en amour
peut constituer un sérieux défi c'est
pas nécessairement comment dire banni ce
que nous on observer mais s'il ya un
hymne un confort de la part des
soignants parce que mes des dirigeants
aussi parce qu'on sait pas jusqu'où ça
va aller
on sait pas jusqu'où est ce que le kobo
vouloir vivre ensemble ce couple là at
il une comment on va l'annoncer aux
autres aussi mais trois au jeune erik
stéphane et guilhem leur amour a été
bien accueillis par leurs familles
il arrive que les enfants soient
réticents à ce que leurs parents
m à nouveau peut-être craint-il la
disparition du patrimoine familial
souvent on va dire à la personnage mais
peut-être que tu german tissu gère mal
ton argent tu géré maltais finances donc
il faut te fie à tes enfants et on va te
donner le conseil justement d'éviter de
naviguer dans des eaux un peu inconnu
avec des gens que tu connais potes je
peux tomber amoureux
tomber amoureux
buzz est donc peut-être que tu es
finances vont être massacrés
[Musique]
c'est bien
c
toutes les études montrent que vieillir
avec la connotation le de dette sur une
pente de sang
c'est quand on arrête d'avoir des
projets et l'amour dont ça fait pas
clockers sa nourrice et un projet
as tellement bon
des fois comme l'adolescente d'autres
sites de test mais qui plus le cdb point
feuille devant des bijoux et d'avoir une
bonne allure raté cultures du coeur même
jeu tafia
c'est encore plus avec roger parce que
ton goût de plaire toujours à turner
bientôt faire tatouer mais attendant moi
aussi hier jean gabin de khenchla songe
qu'à quelqu'un vous m
il fallait être ré so je le sais je peux
pas mieux dire
il fait très beau s'est entraîné par
quelqu'un sait vraiment
formidable
moi qui suis l'automne de ma vie
[Musique]
blister
mais jamais
m